充実した姫それは何よりこんにちははじめ超ですだけで今体育館にてマスケットをし
てるんですけどもう
スポーツ目でしっかり周りが見えていることすごい大事なんですよ
バスケットボールもやっぱりボールが蹴れるシュートも打てないし人が見えないとパス
もできないんですよそんな中
ものすごいアイテムを見つけましたこちら
症状下坂 summer sunglasses
ああああああ
暗いブラウンチャレンジゲームっていうじゃありませんこれどんなものができますと
スカーレット
上下近くになるんですか世界が一変つけてみます
[音楽]
綿製どういうことをこれを知りませんだ
4倍まずで非常に住んで待ってました
与え2回くれてるん
そうなこれフェルト上下が逆さまになるんであーケットボルトいうのマジ6月にパソ
ちょっとしんどいってみますねなぜこれさが玉ところだねぇ
菅澤どころじゃないん
[音楽]
てくださいっ
チョコですねー
訴え事故パパキャッチでやばいん
これは八重が入った北太樹たいきかこれはガチでヤバいぞ
で実習で打ってみシュートに俺が見える俺
はめますよパスを上げてやいいですよ
[音楽]
気血ねっ無理だってこれウ
ねぇやばいやばいもちゃもんだ結構ありがたいですよねとっている
何をとってんだ俺は今うシュート打ってみとりあえずベルそこそこするぞ
っと1回とって言ってんだ
えっ
持った
入っか入ったらこれ今回4つ準備したんでこれ読んだ読んで試合でしたらあマジで
難しいと思うね今日それをやってみたいと思います
うふっ
あ15周5000 mah
家からすぐバック2台にしていくと思うんですけど
その3クロスを付けて下さい入ってあっに酔っちゃうよ
はい化学マジで路線じゃ
ズレああ
これが止まみんな世界が上下反映しておりますはいはいこれで末家に体にしていき
ましょう
ああ
[拍手]
etsuko ても客だったーってなってるんだから
えっなにこれどんな戻っ圭佑とこれ旦那にこれが俺ああこれねはず
プレイ付けた俺って歌いいいいいとあった軍隊たら秩父でパイ編集やってみましょう
はいます頑張るなああああああ
んさあやってまいりましたバスケットボール
象牙逆さまカップ日本大城選手権決勝戦でございますはい肌に台なので
it のディフェンスの選手にボールを渡してから試合が始まりますさあボールを
渡そうとしているがいまいち上下が逆さまよくわからないボールが渡せるか私ないか
今ボールがディフェンスにわたり
それを返してから試合が始まりますさあボールが返せるか解せないから返せん
ないを何とかつかんだ3試合がございました
動きました次第がドリブルは初めて者バスケットボール経験があるんでしっかり作る
様子です
鳥苦労してなるべく中に入って行くがまあなんかちょっとあの事故つないですねやはり
上下が逆ということでなかなか
パスしたパスが通らね家までになっちゃったケースおねしょやっぱり逆さまなでボール
が強い生まれだからいい引き落ちてくるような感覚
ボールを取りに行くがなかなかボールとの距離感がつかめないはいはい歩きでボールに
つけていきますさあボールはどうなるのか
リリースをする分にはこう体をくっつけてはわかりやすいのテレビまたでメイサ c
やすい様子ですさあこれは圭佑に移った青チームボールをどうするか
ボールなはじめ選手に取るがボールが入ったこれが通らない
両選手どこ行ったということでホールが遅れてしまうた立つ選手取りに行く
使ったわれ
西バスケットボールの根本的なルール戦という概念がなくなりましたもうはや別の
スポーツですさあシャルケにデータ異例のまま緑チームのボールでパスが通らん
ないあー怖いもう腰でつけてしまいますさボールを追いかけるみんなはまるで号きんぐ
でっどのよう
さあけってボールが取れずに股をくぐっていくこれやスルーパスでうまいこと初めてに
つながれかと思ったら初めて死も取れない
俺がまた後ろのほうに転がっていくみんな追いかける後ろ姿
これはまるでウォーキングで他のようなさあなかなか4月末天井が止まったの緑チーム
ともたからなぜ過去ログ
ボールが転がっていくタッチ選手それをお前雪できると思ったら
ケースキがボールを取れない転がっていくボールもうなんか4人ともやばいも
なんだかを逆さまになるわけでこんなにバスケットボールと難しくなるのか非常に醜い
スポーツに乗っています
ボールが結婚してどんどんはずこれはキャッツい
できるだとった初めてしてさあ逆逆逆
ゴールド子ですとわかんないよねそうですねちゃったーーーー
入るわけ簿ないってああいうボールでゴールが後ろいてしました
声で威嚇する最低な選手権福井選手3ドリブルしてゴールの下からボールをはじめに
つなぐ
通らないまたはいそれヤバイってとレディーとか大変なんですよ俺だけでみんなを助け
たまえで再び某キングでとのようだ
さあまーだで対0ですみどり市へのドリブルでトマトグッズボールを刻んでいく多数党
いうか
頭がないもうダメです傷をに醜い試合が続いております話ですてボールを取りに行く
撮ったやつでフォロー取ったパスしたがさあまだパスが通らないボールが転がって行く
たんだこれ圭佑パスが通ってると思ってるみたいですね
[拍手]
さあ次第ですね緑チームなんかそれっぽくなってきましたね5兄退任の感じが出てい
ますそれぞれで違ってし詰めていく
を
手術できたら危ない
いいかこれゴール者だぞあるぞこれシュートでは定数生き物ってこれさーたん選手
going だって今中東打つ打つ買う打てるか
シュート秋冬
作って船が入って簡便にわかっちゃう俺はいったいゴールが目にめり込んでしまうぞ
足合間まだ0対0のまま初めてずドリブルをしっかりなんだけど技術で何度かドリブル
は感覚でつけるんですけどまた gold 3ds 距離感ですねしまうって言う
ボールが目の前だ
いけるとこれはし後
うんっ
ハイター
パパたんだよ
誰も見てないのでこれはノーカウントですか残念です自分でしゅんとうために入ってる
か入ってないかわからないけどさっパースがあったんだ土行ってしまいましたねこれは
まずボールがまだ終わっています
当たれボールなんか初めてすボールを取りに行くしっかりこのまま線がないゲームなの
でこのままゴールにねじ込みないということがここで頭いっぱいはじめ選手転んで
しまった
再びボウラー緑チームにまあで違ってボールをキープです
移動するドリブルついて
天井を交わしていきたいかなかなか出てたんだからちょっとの激しい道は
グッズがマッチどう入らない
ボールが遠くに行ってしまいます大変でストリーク3のセダンまるでウォーキングって
さあボールの取り合いになるさあ始めとトマトくんのボールの取り合いボーダーと頂点
にわたるかこれは
どうなだけ
パターンはぐれですまた緑チームの頃になるか
オーナー様はただ家の方へ行くがトマト宮福が流されていく
再び試合は戻りデータでのも青チーム her face ドリブルで一気にこれまで
ギュ
これは名アプシェと決まらんんない
かけているのがこの男早速で青チームケーキ走るとボールを投げるえんとなぁケフィア
走ってそのゴールにねじ込みの天井になるっっだというか
使う違う柄で外したり手を合わせて観光をつかむさあこれがこのたタッチするの建設
編集ボールを奪った
そんなまあ緑準備囲まれてるか後ろで派手にパズ
とったいや距離がアルカポネもう一問週間組で集ぞ
ハイター
さあどれも見てませんのーカードでしたねございました
あっハール hel